welcome to forge mastering forge mode
will enable you to build your own maps
for custom games this is also where you
can experiment with different weapons
vehicles objects and effects
there's a lot to learn so let's run
through the basics building in forage is
done in monitor mode monitor mode allows
you to move freely around the map
interact with objects and spawn new
objects into the world let's get started
fly to the first Waypoint
you're almost there but the path is
blocked you'll have to delete these
objects to get through start by
selecting them
okay now delete those objects that'll do
keep moving toward the Waypoint use the
boost if you want to move faster
come for your next lesson let's try to
build a man cannon our Forge objects are
stored in the object library open it up
and find the man cannon
man cannons should be placed at
strategic locations that area should
work
good work man cannons can launch things
for a considerable distance now set up
the man cannon to reach that platform
right now the man cannon is pointing in
the wrong direction so you'll have to
rotate it
here's where things get interesting
every object has its own adjustable
properties there are a lot of variables
to experiment with but for now let's
adjust the man cannons trajectory if you
want to reach your target you'll have to
increase the values in the launcher
section
to test the man cannon you'll have to
switch back to Spartan mode all right
give it a shot
hey you flew pretty good looks like you
know the forge basics you'll pick up the
rest as you experiment we've covered how
to move around the map switch between
monitor and Spartan mode and how to
place move and change the properties of
objects remember to save your progress
as you go if you need inspiration keep
an eye open for more intel on Halo
Waypoint or on halo forge community
sites good luck out there
you